вимагаю тут в авдіївці початком нової
масштабної фази війни на сході України
активка а де коинов кілочки райони
завжди був і гарячу точку і розумно маму
ж бачу і тут захід будь-які однак сама в
рамку мило і знайди ми спустили а йому
гаспарян застрелені ну ми на руку валу
на 10000 порушено перемир'я в темній
регіоні pro team 1 дня з найвищою рівнею
доручених їм заарештували за ви зараз
нашу роботу в Україні ціна єдиний центр
обстрілявши думаємо про таку ситуацію пити
та не чисто не регіону прийду за
маріуполя то на сході мем із самих
світлодарське дебальцеве причина цикл я
хочу це ціна щось близько beats and
storing він пункт 1 різновид дверей та
атака що й факт 6 ну та се навіки була
башкаус брови не на тому місці вона
повернула назад на лінію розмішування
smm bc документа та civic то дикістю у
хату і не стріляють засіки пу-1 since it
opened in the ground during праця аніонів
.
і кимчі нам можливо ти в полоні таємниця про
б дві сторони ще он і при панелі
стріляну на
він у душі про машини рамках ми можемо
організувати та проводити у місті
сторонам та рахунків становлення примор'я
для того, щоб дромунд води ж тіло
накидні об'єкти інфраструктури ціни дуб
відривала перемир'я там ще цінна поступаючись
причому стрілі нині а причина знову
повторюся всі пресують немає божкова вас
бійня близьких позицій сторін конфлікту 1
до 1 і сам [ __ ] зраду але вище
перспективу перестануть другу тревал їм і
обстрілу і ким і заросла ми чуємо в'язень
нути ось ти замкнув а тато крем вашої
роботи відразу травня буде роббана у
політичний площі рахунок наріжте
знаєте мирні ви вирішення important that
навіть важливого рахунок простіше бік давно
вдома владу заразною ріжте було за
право джона політика убог старовинний раз
заявляла про свій зручний звук
анатолійської в молодості
ціни заради їжі на платформу для
стерилізації з туате ми знаємо ще
бік можеш додумати з їхнього думова нас
стоїть куба людина він убитий води башкаус
бійня бо людина він і торкнулася
примор'я
cs випробувань обожнювання та волею повз
проблем із команд
ним і контролюємо, волі складні вирішили
мати наче їх валами
спеціально моніторного місія прибувають
тут ще пити його тисячу бекону ці
рішення і чо вон і за провертайте на
лінії розмежування to contact line